Hey Youtubers! It's Charlie, this is gonna be my Deadpool Easter Egg video
Instead of doing a spoiler review, I figured it'll be a little bit more fun
So definitely big spoiler warning if you haven't seen the movie
Let's start with the biggest one first, we gonna talk post-credits scene
So he's in the Ferris Bueller robe and does the Ferris Bueller's Day Off speech
Life moves pretty fast.
If you don't stop and look around every once in a while, you'll miss it.
I hope you guys took his advice and picked your trash up after the movie too.
A lot of people are using that as prove that Cable's gonna be in the sequel,
But they were saying before the film came out that
if we didn't put cable on the sequel, people would assassinate us.
So Cable showing up in the Deadpool movies was a foregone conclusion.
So not as big a surprise as Ferris bueller 4th wall break.